hey guys pete here getting ready to talk
the expanse season six episode five
as you know why we fight was the
penultimate episode in this short final
season
and i gotta say that i'm not ready for
this thing to end
there's so much good stuff in this
episode and i'm here with benja from
benjatv channel do you want to say hello
hi guys i agree with pete this this is
just too soon for it to end but here we
are
yeah and we'll be talking all things
expanse you can ask us questions about
605 or anything about the expanse in
general
as far as spoilers we won't be talking
about anything beyond this episode of
the tv show so if you're caught up there
you'll be fine and
i think
you know this is
this is probably going to
take a while to get through so we should
probably jump right into it i'll just
say that yeah if you're worried about it
if you're not caught up this is your
chance to leave and let's go and talk
about this x-ray feature first
yes we always start with these ones and
this week's was quite interesting
because
we this this one shows how holden joined
the canterbury crew and i know you've
got a lot to say about this so i'll pass
it over to you
yeah um you know this was
i think i heard about this that they
were gonna do this
in one of the comments on one of my
videos and i was i was
kind of disappointed one because i heard
this was the last x-ray that there
wasn't another one
but
when i first saw this
i was like oh well this is you know this
this shot right here i was like oh well
he looks exactly the same what's going
on you know what i mean and then i was i
was pleasantly surprised when we went
back and um
you know this
this mural i thought that was a great
way to kick things off remembering how
that you know that that whole campaign
of remember the can't back in the early
early part of the story
and um
then they they brought back also a
couple of you know
easy to recognize characters they were
like
these are like
pretty pretty side character you know
they're not they're not like they didn't
have big roles but
very memorable ones so you know what i
mean it was like
oh look it's that guy it's the gun
belter you know and the other guy i
think his name in the credits he was
listed as
what was it like surly belter or
something like that so these characters
they didn't have names because of you
know the role that they played but
it was great to see
captain mcdowell can't come back
i made the connection that he's actually
in station 11 i've been watching that
and i didn't realize it was the same guy
until i saw this
wasn't his wasn't his hair shorter in
season one
yeah i i have a picture of them together
that we'll look at but
i was just gonna say the same thing
they did do a great job of de-aging
holden
oh yeah
mcdowell though he looks exactly like
seven years of has pat you know what i
mean
they didn't do the same for him which is
kind of funny when you think about it
but
he's still recognizable and like i said
we have the gaunt belter he was the face
of series in
episode one this guy right here
he you know he was the one that was
talking about the problems that the
belters face on
series whenever
miller and
adlock were talking and getting oriented
with the area and uh
then this guy
he showed up in
what was it season two episode eight
it's the first episode where we met
prax and
that was just such a great scene that he
was involved in he can't he came do you
remember this one he came in and he not
really
he separated out the the people from the
inner planets
he said oh we're going to transfer you
to another ship and he ends up spacing
them
so you know he had just met this
character prax and and he's you know
being brought back by this woman that he
knew from
ganymede who happened to be an earther
or a martian i don't remember what her
backstory was but
our introduction to him and to this
situation was
him watching his friend get spaced which
was was crazy
yeah it was
yeah so i really liked how they how they
did that with this and
these guys you know they popped up and
it's it's fun to see that and
it's not it's not superfluous you know i
mean they have a
they had a memorable role in the series
so it's nice to bring them back at the
end to
kind of
tie things up
yeah so yeah what did you think about
young holden here
i mean i think people are saying that ty
confirmed
that he just shaved and they didn't do
anything special to
i guess the
agent so yeah that's what i heard
i guess you know
i'm like that too if i shave i look i
look at least five years younger i guess
that's what they did here but i think he
did look younger
they did a good job him
um yeah yeah i i thought they did a
fantastic job showing where he came from
yeah
what a journey this guy's had from
literally just looking to do the least
amount possible and skate by without any
real responsibility
the show never really had a chance to
make that part of his character as clear
as it is when you read the book because
you know you have his thought process
there
and even though he's
he's clearly like a reluctant hero type
in the show and his idealistic nature
causes him problems
i always enjoy that added dimension to
the character that
he's more than that he's actually kind
of a slacker he gets kicked out of the
navy and then
he's just trying to get by without any
problems
and then you look at everything that
happened in the last six seasons and
it's pretty pretty hilarious
and the chance occurrence of the way
that mcdowell met him that we see here
in this short
and how that led to him crewing up and
meeting the future rossi family
it's a perfect reminder for how epic the
journey they've all had together is
going
i mean
it's a perfect reminder of that of that
journey and
what a fun setup for the series finale
i'm really going to miss this show and
i'm
it's just there's so many there's just
it's it's a great it's a great um
full circle kind of moment
yeah i think that i think it was neat
because it makes you think you know
if it wasn't for this
uh binary if holden didn't make the
right binary decision here and he said
no to join up
none of what we show none of what we see
on the show would have happened this
would have been a completely different
timeline so
all of what we've seen comes to this one
single decision
and i guess that makes this x-ray
episode the more the most
important one among all the ones we've
had
so i think that part is quite neat if
this was a network show for example they
with 22 episodes per season they could
have done an episode where
holden doesn't join up with the crew and
they show this alternative timeline that
made me think of that
this this single decision changed the
course of history so so this extra
episode was by far by far my favorite
yeah absolutely i mean amos references
this later whenever he's in series at a
bar
also
about how
holden literally saved all of humanity a
couple of times in this series so
yeah it would have been quite of
different if this had not happened it
would have been a quite quite a
different setup
and who knows who would have been who
would have stepped into that role
uh should we move on to laconia or do
you have something else to say
yeah i just wanted to say here's a
picture of them and whenever he's in the
scene from uh season one where he's
trying to get him to take on the xo role
and he just doesn't want to have
anything to do with it he just doesn't
want the responsibility at all
and as he has looked at mcdowell man
he looks nothing like his current state
yeah so yeah i think we can move on to
laconia now
right there we see that cara's idea to
concord fixes dead brother zan works and
this is where we'll start our actual
episode discussion
uh what did you what did you think about
the sequence because
we all kind of us non-book readers kind
of guessed this this is where it was
going
but um we knew there would be a twist
and the twist was that zan doesn't
really appear
how good is normal i guess
it doesn't exactly appear normal how did
you what did you think about this
sequence
well i think that there's not a whole i
don't think there's really a whole lot
we can say or we should say at this
point because there's
this this one out of all of them seemed
like a part one of two
you know what i mean like they they sort
of stopped this and at a point where
you're not supposed to know exactly
what's going on with him
i think that it was super fun i thought
that i was when i was re-watching this
again yesterday i thought that the one
line where
she's talking to him
about that he got killed you know you
got hurt and you got hurt bad you got
killed and he's just like oh
i thought that was i thought that was
super funny like he
but i mean there was one thing that i
didn't really mention in my recap and
that was that he uses the word substrate
and that's interesting for book readers
i don't think miller ever used the term
in the show
but that first comes up whenever he's
talking to holden about why he needs him
to connect the circuit in the ring
station
which happened in season three episode
10.
he needs him because he exists in the
physical world and that is they refer to
that as the substrate
and they is mysterious in that
you don't know who they are
but this idea of substrate is being in
the physical world
so but he is back
he's in i guess
his personality seems he knows his
sister
he answers her questions as if
he understands who she is and what's
going on
there's definitely some other stuff i
mean
he there's a there's a shot here where
he says i've never seen that before and
he looks and there's nothing there so
it's something that he can see that she
can't see
and i think you know since i know what's
going to happen i i what i think what a
question i want to ask a non-book reader
is
how do you think he's going to be
received by the other laconians
do you think the dogs actually fixed him
or what do you think is going on here i
think they're gonna freak out naturally
because
uh i think they made a point to show
that um almost everybody visited um
zan's wake
even duarte was there so they saw his
dead body with their own eyes
i think they put that scene there
intentionally
because they've seen his dead body and
now they're gonna just freak out not
understanding how he can be alive
and
they're gonna they're gonna i guess
treat him like a creature in my opinion
i'm not sure if that's what's gonna
happen but
if i know anything about
humanity that's what's gonna happen
he might be treated really harshly they
might do experiments on him
so rough going
yeah i i i touched on this a bit in the
last live stream so i don't want to
dwell too long because we have so much
other stuff to get into but that's what
i said about this book that i always
liked is that
it's from a kid's perspective
so the way she reacts to him
she doesn't even she's just like cool i
had this problem and it got solved you
know
my brother was dead and now he's not
let's party you know what i mean let's
and so yeah
you're right to think that
the grown-ups and the people who are in
charge there aren't going to
aren't likely to react in the same way
especially you know if the black eyes
remain just black
that's not gonna be good for him
yeah i don't know how well you can see
it on the screen but their skin is quite
different too um
whenever this you know his skin is like
it's supposed to be
kind of gray and black and and his
movements are also
noticeably different
so he's he's definitely creepy
yeah
uh i guess we you we could probably move
on from there i i think maybe we could
talk a little bit more about this at the
end as it relates to some of the other
things that are going on though
exactly
[Music]
do you want to read the super chat
yeah so
tm martin
thank you for the five dollars hi pete
benja and all
any truth to the rumors there's going to
be an expanse movie special with the
time jump
i'm not sure exactly
what rumors
you're referring to there was a article
that came out maybe two weeks ago
that said that there was talks going on
and tai did debunk that he said that
that was completely fiction that was
complete work of fiction the guy who
wrote the article just made it up
that they and that they want to do it
but they don't have any offers
at least that's what he said in in his
tweet so i i think anything that's
saying that there's going to be a movie
special is just speculation at this
point
yeah i think we talked about this a
couple of streams ago as well
and i said
we've never heard anybody making things
up on the internet so don't yeah don't
believe everything you read on you you
read on here so especially with stuff
like this that people really like and
they want it to continue so people so
you know writers are gonna
news writers or article writers are
gonna
probably make some things up but you
don't believe everything you hear
would be yeah i could i could definitely
put out a video tomorrow that said
something similar to that
exactly and i can i can anticipate that
it would have
a lot of views
it wouldn't make it true though
unfortunately
if only if only i mean
imagine you're saying something and then
it's coming through
magic
i think we can move on to the soul ring
because we have an amazing scene here
uh there's another big reveal after the
the cornea scene we watched the mcrn try
to capture the soldering but they're in
for a rude awakening turns out the free
navy has placed railguns on the ring
station surface and they destroy the
martian fleet that's attacking the ring
carino who just came back to the show is
among the casualties
there's nothing there's nothing quite
like a battle scene from the expanse is
there so
on top of the great action this one also
features an interesting twist
with the with the ring station
railguns
i guess rsrg stands for that
so i'm curious to hear what you have to
say here please
well i have to say r.i.p carino for sure
they brought her back rip
and yeah she's um
no longer with us
i guess this felt like a completely
planned or i felt like it was
competently planned and
they did everything right here it looked
like it was a well executed sneak attack
that resulted in a massive loss of life
and ships for the mcrn
we'll talk more about the railguns in a
bit but one thing that i liked about
this scene was the way that it opened
with the flying torpedo
it was kind of flying in silence
and then the way it drew back
as the score kicked in i thought that
was really cool and the way that they
framed the ring the ring gate like
across the screen horizontally instead
of the normal way where we see it i
thought that was all those were all
really interesting decisions
and
you know like i said we'll talk a little
bit more about the rail guns but i think
the big takeaway from this is that
this was a competent
plan
with the high-tech the most high-tech
ships that they have
and they all got wiped out wiped out
like
no problem
yeah and
i guess we can move on to the pella
because uh marco's getting a little bit
worried about his movement
his calls because uh drummer put a
spanner in the works with her statement
and rosenfeld thinks they should just
focus on getting to medina and
controlling the ring gate because that's
where the real prize is if you control
that you control access to 1300 systems
and during this conversation they learn
about the failed mcrn attack we just
talked about at the ringgate which
obviously boosts their morale
and like you said this was a really
solid plan marco had and now
they're burning towards the ring gates
to establish their new base of
operations
and
what do you think about this this plan
by marco and um
i guess i can't ask you if if he's going
to be successful
but um
well i think does it sound solid to you
yeah
yeah i think this is really the first
time we get the full picture of what
he's planning
in the show we don't get to see this he
shifts
you know he's he's he actually changes
his mind and and decides to go this way
and here it's all been kind of
mysterious but now that it's out there
you have to give him credit i think
this is a solid plan
it's actually similar to what fred
johnson like was planning to do his big
plan for medina station and how he
wanted to be
keep the belt involved and
he was doing it in that way of like they
were gonna have medina
he was gonna they were gonna have to go
through him but he was gonna try to use
that politically
to work with them and increase his own
standing and his own ability to
talk to and
influence the inners here marco's just
taking it over he's reinforcing it
and
yeah this is a good this is like he can
everything that everything that
rosenfeld said to him to
get him back on track after he sort of
got upset about
iopidis
was true
and that's why he did it and she
understands this and she's just
reinforcing it
yeah
whenever they have control of that choke
point
and all the resources and everything
else that are beyond those rings
that exactly same line makes me think
this is just too good to be true for
marco
because where is he getting those guns
you know
and how
uh
are the people's
you know are people giving him the
material to make those uh railgun
systems
really going to let him uh
keep controlling the ring i don't know
that just made me think of that
so it's an interesting question you
bring up
one that i can't answer obviously yeah
exactly
but you know keep your eyes appealed i
guess because
um
they can't you know
whoever's giving
where is helping marco i guess we'll
discuss that when we move on to the
zenobia as well
uh whoever's giving him the material to
the metal to make those weapons
uh
they must they must have a plan in mind
to
take care of marco once
he served his purpose i suppose
yeah and they do make it explicit that
it's coming from laconia
the rail guns were were assembled and
delivered
from from the laconia system
but that's all we know about it right
now
i guess we can move move on to the
zenobia to talk about
the weapon system as well then
since we're on the subject
yep
are we
checking on the zenobia to find out how
they are reacting to the ring gate news
they know that the railgun is a martian
design but the metal it's made out of is
something they've never seen before
the metal is from like you said from a
planet in the laconia system
and i tried to listen to this part
carefully to understand how they
installed the weapons how all of this
works and from what i understand the
setup is practically impenetrable is
that right
yeah i was wondering how how the i mean
obviously when you read the book you get
the whole idea of how they're installing
it and everything in the show they
decided to keep that as a mystery
but
i was wondering if people were picking
up on on what's actually going on here
because the the rain the the railguns
are mounted on the surface they can't
drill into the surface of the ring
station it just doesn't work
so what they did was they made these
giant bands
titanium bands that
wrap all the way around
and sort of hold it
in these different you know there's six
of the rail guns
and they're in different places all all
sort of together
and it the setup is badass it's like
it's basically
flawless as a defense system
um
as you like if you
they mentioned the infinite inertia and
that's the thing is is when you fire a
giant rail gun like that
it has there's a there's a there's an
equal and opposite reaction
because of the way that the
this ring station is it doesn't move
that energy goes somewhere but it
doesn't affect it in in the space
so when they fire it there's no recoil
or kickback or whatever you call it in a
railgun
it just sits there perfectly
so they can they can just fire they can
just aim and fire in all of those
different directions
throughout the the ring space
and that's just that's how they just
made a meal out of them crn
yeah because there's only
they have the advan they have they have
the advantage of surprise there as well
but
there's really no time to react it's
it's it's
you know it's a short
relatively speaking in the giant expanse
of space it's a relatively
short
amount of
distance that that has to to cover once
they start to shoot at those ships
so this new information puts the inners
in a difficult spot as they have to
capture marco before he gets to the ring
gate
but if they go after him now they'd have
to abandon series so they've got a
tough choice to make and even if they go
ahead and enact this plan to go after
marco
there's a chance they will fail
and in this situation you don't want to
be the one having to make the tough
choices do you
no it's difficult because
of the reasons that you just laid out
and
as you watch them talk through the
options they they bring up the idea of
just shooting a bunch of fast nukes in
there
we know what happened when they
detonated a nuke
near the station
it's definitely something that has a lot
of unknowns in it like what's gonna
happen after we do that and
there is the potential for the ring
station to
destroy entire systems
that's happened you know so
they don't they have to be careful in
that regard and when you hear them talk
to the options you get a pretty good
idea that
besides the mistake of going after the
rossi
marco did have he's he's doing
he's doing pretty well he has a decent
strategy to fall back on even after he
lost the azor dragon and all the rocks
that were pointed at earth
i yeah so i think that that's one of the
i mean i think
obviously how how strong of a defense
this is
and just how if he does get there
they'll be able to stay there for ever
yeah you know that you know i mean it's
just the way it is and
i i wonder you know
she whenever bobby and abu sarah are
talking
she feels
that she may have made a mistake about
not sending ships with carino
my thought
was that it really wouldn't have changed
much in this engagement
maybe they would have been able to keep
some people back
but i don't think more more ships would
have actually you know
done the job of overtaking this the ring
space so
i think it all goes to that there's
there's one part about this that kind of
you know it seems to me that you sort of
have to overlook the idea that they
don't have any intelligence assets or
some way of finding out what he's doing
inside the ring in order for this to be
the surprise that it turned out to be
but as it stands
it seems to be impenetrable
there's not
you know
there's no good options here other than
to chase him which we know is pretty
terrible also
yeah and because of this barbie gives a
lazarella a pep talk
after everyone else leaves and
bobby i thought was almost speaking for
the audience here because um
he was trying to boost vasara's morale
you know it was a great moment because
also allah needed us this isn't the time
to ponder over your feelings and bobby
let her knew
how did you react to this interaction
did you did bobby
did bobby surprise you because
she was talking to the secretary general
this way
yeah i loved it for that reason i liked
how you saw her
it takes her a minute to get there
avasarala has to actually push her
buttons she's not doing it on purpose
but that's the way it plays out right
yeah and
avastarella's second guessing herself
makes total sense because she's got all
these different things going on so yeah
you know i
i get that and bob but bobby is right
there's not
there's there's no there's no easy
choices but
the choice to not fight back isn't
really going to
it's going to guarantee that he gets in
there and he has control of that ring
space and that'll be on her that'll
everyone in the rest of soul system
will be thinking that she dropped the
ball
and so unfortunately or maybe
fortunately considering where this takes
us and we'll get to that in a minute but
they're going to need some help here
they can't actually
do it on their own
yeah which is why
our last exam but before we get to that
we have two scenes on the rossi
one of them involves clarissa and holden
as she tells him that the un engineers
want to reinforce the rousey's role
all
this reminds clarissa of her father jill
pierre mao because
this all i guess is from auto molecule
research
and this is the second callback to
julpir mao this season we had the x-ray
episode about him and clarissa
and she thinks this makes it seem like
he was right to continue experimenting
with the product molecule because
they're now benefiting from it
what do you what did you think about
this short scene here
yeah i didn't really touch on this
clarissa conversation in my recap
and i like how it brings to mind the
inevitability of humans using the
proto-molecule to advance things
this carbon silicate
uh plating that she's talking about
it's only possible by them studying the
proto molecule
and we saw some of this with prax as
well his his food solution
also comes from some of that research
and
larissa is torn personally because of
the mess the methods that her father
used and the lengths he went to try to
control it
he was responsible for a lot of dead
people
i mean eros um
project caliban with the children and
the hybrids
basically just using people as guinea
pigs and he started a war to
[Music]
you know get hit get keep
people from looking into what he was
doing so he's
did things in a very bad way and you
know that's that's not really a question
but as dastardly as he was there was
some truth in his belief that someone
was going to do what he did
he he looked at it from
you know
he just
it might as well be him because he was
powerful enough that no one could stop
him or even really tell him that he was
wrong
and he just went to town because it
would have made him the most powerful
person in the solar system
but you know the advancements were going
to come of this and
i guess you know the the way that it
would be
you know the way that it would work out
the best is if everyone had a sample of
it
and everyone was able to
you know do their
do their research and share their
results but
that's not the way it played out so yeah
it's interesting to see that through the
lens of clarissa it it does make that
x-ray
a little more poignant in that situation
too
with her dealing with his loss and
yeah i thought this was a this
is there's not a really a lot of time
for this season to to explore this side
of it but i i thought this was uh
something that needed a little more
conversation because it
you know there is a parallel to what's
happening on laconia
but duarte
at the same time
yeah and if this season was longer i
think uh i'm not i'm not sure if this is
in the books but i think we might have
seen prax
actually on the show having his own
storyline instead of just a message
i think that would have been great if
the season was longer
yeah they in the books it there are he
has he comes back as a point of view
character and it does it shows what the
occupation of ganymede underneath the
free navy looks like
and that's the side story as he's
developing that and he eventually gets
it to to to earth
and tai did say that
they had in their initial plan when they
they didn't know they had to pare it
down to six episodes that that was one
of the things that they were gonna that
they had to cut was was prax's storyline
yeah that's a shame
um we can move on to dr elvio correa she
makes an appearance to inform naomi
about the missing ship data she believes
there's a mass energy threshold that
proceeds or maybe even triggers the
disappearance events so every time
someone travels through the ring gate
there's a chance the unknown aggressors
the orange entities
will appear again
and
what what did you what did you make of
this piece
because i was glad to see okoye once
again
she
i think she sent the message she sent a
message to holden in season five as well
and um yeah
so uh yeah
yeah it's nice to see elvie make an
appearance
she's a a recurring character
she's a recurring character in the books
and
one of my favorites
it does look like here that she made it
off of villas that's the last i think
the the message she sent to holden
last season that came from ellis so she
had still been there
now this this message says that
she was sending it from europa lab so i
guess she's near jupiter in the jupiter
system
yeah i'm glad they that they
were able to incorporate some of these
people
what she has found here
is is pretty big is pretty big
information
it's one of those things where you don't
really know how that can
what can be done about it and because of
everything else that's going on no one's
really going to pay attention to this
we'll see that in the next
uh interaction between holden and and
abisarala
but what was your take on what she was
saying did you did you have any ideas
about that because obviously i know what
what what she's talking about here
yeah and
i think um
this goes back to
what holden was saying
you know a few seasons ago last season
uh he was talking about how
these
these unknown aggressors were um
were getting angry whenever they
traveled when whenever humans traveled
through the ring gates
and uh
it is theorized that they destroyed the
paramolecule civilization
so
and this is and this mass energy
threshold i suppose is
whenever
uh whenever there is there's a
massive discharge of energy that uh
that goes above a certain threshold they
um
they appear once again and attack
it's a good it's a good i i mean i i can
follow what you're saying i can't
confirm or deny anything about it but
it's amazing obviously i mean you know
why you know you know whenever they end
the season with
uh
this happening to the bar keith that
it's going to be important later
yeah my problem is you know
we had bar keith last season so i was
without knowing about the books i was
expecting this storyline to play a more
active role
so
you know from a number created
perspective this is
this the progress on this storyline has
been a little bit disappointing
yeah i see
yeah they changed it up a lot in the tv
show too because in in the book
naomi gets obsessed with this on her own
in relation to they're all getting
debriefed and she's getting really she's
getting it really bad because she was
actually
she's the person that knows marco better
than anyone
that they you know so they want to know
everything about that so they're
trying to interrogate her and figure out
like what's going on the issue
can they trust her and
what does she know that she can tell
them about marco so that they can get
rid of him
and so she she goes in and she's also
lost because of what happened with
phillip and the whole situation
so she kind of gets obsessed with
solving this problem
i liked how they did that here where
they just sort of used it to show like
holden
gets interested first and then
they sort of they sort of used it to
show how their relationship is and they
used it you know he says i'll give you
this problem and she realizes he's doing
that because
it'll make her feel better i thought
that part was was pretty cool
she figured it out in the books by
herself and so elvie is is kind of an
addition here
i mean i i guess it's all good i guess i
i i kind of i kind of like that she
figured it out in the books by herself
but i don't think it really changes
things too much
yeah
i guess we can move on to the tynan now
drummer is closing in our series with
the cargo she liberated liberated but
u.n officers are trying to make this
difficult
for her and
her ships azralla intervenes to say
drummer and her crew are welcome on the
station
and she tries to arrange a meeting
here but the drummer asserts she's there
for the belters not of us
i definitely appreciated ava sorella's
confidence here i think she knew
she knew what drummer's reaction would
be
but uh would you turn down a meeting
with the secretary general pete because
drama did and it absolutely suits your
character
yeah it is pretty boss boss like i think
to do that
i mean that would be the you know if the
president or
prime minister of wherever called you up
and said hey i wanted to have a
conversation with you you're like no i'm
good i'm kind of busy right now
doing a live stream with pete right now
so i can't i can't answer yeah and i you
know i think that
i thought this was just flat out funny i
mean it's not
it's it's lighthearted and i thought
that was great and i thought it was
delivered perfectly by keraje
she basically does the whole cycle of
everything you can ask an actor to do in
this episode
i mean there's obviously some really
heavy stuff we're going to be getting to
but i thought she did this
absolutely
i mean these two coming back and forth
like if you think about the this is the
setup for the big intense showdown at
the end of the episode
and here you can see them you know just
with these little character interaction
that's just fantastic
yeah nike we can
talk about that heavy heavy stuff
starting with joseph because his arm
isn't really growing properly and
they'll have to remove it and redo the
procedure and you can see how much this
hurts drummer
just brutal for joseph
obviously it hurts more but uh
in the meantime drummer gets a message
from naomi as well but uh she doesn't
respond we saw
we saw um
drummer deleting messages from
naomi that she archived
and this was i guess a continuation of
that
now what did you think
yeah i mean i think for one that sad
little baby arm i mean that thing is
that thing was something to look at
wasn't it and it's pretty messed up that
he can't take pain meds he's like in all
this pain and the guy says no if you if
you do that it'll just confuse the gel
and they'll start growing more nerves
for more pain you know
that sounds
awful
but yeah um you know her her choice not
to answer naomi's message it was a big
it's a big choice and
it kind of hits different if you didn't
watch the x-ray episode where she
deleted all those saved messages at the
end
um
i thought that was i thought that was
interesting it's been clear that she has
she has
more i mean she's in a re unrequited
love situation with naomi
he's in love with her she wants her to
be a part of this thing that she has
going on and
naomi's dedicated to holden she's not
she's she has feelings for drummer but
they're not the same
and
the writers have made that clear in
different things
you know they've clarified that just in
case because
maybe in the show there's there's it
feels like there's a possibility that
there's more to it and you can have that
but at least for where they're at right
now in the story
naomi is not conflicted she's she's she
knows where she wants to be she wants to
be with holden in that
monogamous monogamous relationship with
him
and so that anka walla clip from earlier
the the first x-ray
it showed that she's trying to find some
resolution because she's not going to
get the outcome she wants and these
feelings have cost her so much in
relation to her family and that's
continuing to play out here
and then she gets this message and you
can see
you know that feeling you know whenever
you see that message from that person
that has that kind of hold on you and
you think
you know i got other stuff going on here
i don't want to think about
i don't want to think about naomi but
exactly
you know
it's it's it's it's an interesting setup
for what we're going to see later
yeah we'll we'll get to that later uh
but we we have another scene from the
pella as philip learns that tadeo is in
the brick because he tried to get in
touch with his brother on series
which is obviously not something that's
allowed
phillip feels bad for him and finds out
that tadeo's brother is dead
tadio stuns because he was on the crew
that planted the bombs and rick the
docks to blow so he holds himself
responsible
they assured him that belters wouldn't
get hers but
here he is his brother is dead
i guess this was quite an interesting
moment for tadeo but it was also
interesting for philip did you expect to
see this emotional moments between them
i was actually a little surprised at how
well this interaction with these two
came off
it's a little wedged in there with
everything else that's going on like it
there's
these as you see if you think about the
hierarchy of characters that we spent
time with
and the the just the intense
dramatic showdowns and conversations and
things that happen this is kind of
pretty low on that on that scale on that
list right and i think both of the
actors
they made it work pretty well and you
know just building off that little bit
of time they had together in the repair
skiff
and i you know i feel bad for the for
today oh here
it's a tough situation and it's the kind
of thing that sticks with you you know
yeah
and
it once again shows how the free navy
and marco's plans
manipulate
these people
absolutely and he you know he can blame
himself he he will
probably blame himself for the rest of
his life
you can tell him objectively or you
could tell him you know hey
it's not your fault but this is the kind
of thing that you never really shake and
and
that kind of
that's going on with so many different
people on so many levels as a result of
this war right
yeah and people in the chat a few people
are saying
i don't know you i'm naive are you to
think that uh belters wouldn't get hurt
but you know we have examples of similar
things in the real world
where people think they're on they think
they're only hurting the enemy but
you know i won't go into details here
but
i think yeah i think it's just what i'm
saying
yeah it's just a complicated nature of
this
he doesn't have a choice that's the
story he has to tell himself
to be able to sleep at night it doesn't
matter if it's if it's naive or not he's
in a situation where he signed up
this is his life
he's got to do a job and
he's going to grasp on to that idea that
nobody else is going to get hurt only
the right people are going to get hurt
because that's what you have to do in
order to function
in a situation like that that's the
human side of it right
yeah and
i did see an interesting comment here
i'm not sure if it's true but i wanted
to ask you about this he says the bomb
said
martian stealth deck adding editing he
says this
uh
could this be true because
yeah because they weren't spotted
i mean
i had never i had never
i never real i mean
i understand thinking that there's
something going on there why they
wouldn't have been able to find them but
i i have never i'll honestly have had
not thought about that
until right this second
i don't think they do a good job of
explaining how they were able to
hide those there i mean you would think
that they would have come in with some
pretty good sweeping technology to be
able to find anything that was there and
they didn't find them and this didn't
happen they didn't it didn't explode
right when they got there there was
there was a delay
i don't think that i don't recall the
show
actually i don't think the show did that
yeah no
the show didn't address it
um i think we can move on to rosenfeld
as she continues to be a great exo
she boosts the crew's morale by gifting
them a rare earther bandy to celebrate
the victory at the gate
he also shows marco the speech his son
i gave after drummer's message trying to
prove to marco that phillip is not a
lost cause
so
this is getting i
i don't want to say
over the top but
rosenfeld is i think playing a much
bigger role than i thought
she she is involved in every decision
marco makes and she always right tries
to steer marco
i'm not sure if this much involvement
by her
is totally realistic uh what do you
think
now this part that wasn't isn't isn't
what bothered me by the way but uh her
overall involvement in
marco's every single decision is
a little bit over the top i think
i i don't know i i mean i i think that
there has to be someone that to fill
that void there's no one
i mean i guess they could maybe have
done a better job of showing other
people
jockeying for a position at his side or
something like that but
i think
i think you know my takeaway from the
character was just that
she was smart enough to know how to
stroke margo's marco's ego
and you know you see another example of
it here where he she's showing him
something his son did and he's like oh i
wonder where he got that from you know
good old dad you know so
yeah i i don't know i i i i didn't real
i just figured that these two like he
needs somebody to be there when philip
isn't and that's really the void that
she she's keying up on that that that is
there if things had been if things had
gone right between philip and marco it
would be them standing there talking
strategy
so you know that
i i think that my takeaway on the
character was just that
they can read the situation they can
pick up on when there's an opportunity
and they can actually capitalize on that
and she's now in line to be
the governor of medina station so
yeah
i said last week if
i was wondering if you know she would
turn on marco but
i'm still thinking about that maybe
she's gonna strike a deal with whoever's
gunning for marco
maybe someone in laconia i don't know
my theory mind is going
insane right now
i think we can move on to zenobia
avasarala and holden are reunited
she was with monica before holden
arrived so we'll talk about that first
we learned that the lucky earther piece
has done well
avasarala mentions that the praxis
findings look promising as well and they
might be able to up the food product
production on earth
and lastly we see avasarala taking an
injection just as holden arrives
we see we saw that we saw in an x-ray
episode that
avasarala wasn't in a great
condition in terms of health
and these injections
sound intriguing what do you think
yeah i i i actually this is something i
don't really know what's going on
i thought this was kind of surprising
when she did that but the first time i
watched it i hadn't seen the x-ray
though so i wasn't it was really out of
context
i i guess i mean she mentioned she was
getting a medication from the doctor
when we saw that health check on her her
tablet
it was mostly exhaustion
it was from what you could read and
it was saying that she should need to
get she needed to get rest
which obviously she's not doing
so i guess that this could this could be
a medication from the doctor that's
related to
some underlying thing or it just could
be what she's saying that it's a
stimulant so that she can
power through
i'm not sure if i'm missing something
with that or not i think that that's
that's it's
you know she's burning the candle at
both ends and
he's
hitting up the doctor for some some
feel-good stuff to to make it through
i also i also liked it when um
also allah said
i shoot up my dosage and
yeah holden was like what what what are
you talking about that part was pretty
funny as well this one had quite a few
funny moments this episode
but holden is mainly there to uh share
okoye's findings with
sorry he holden wants to share okay's
findings with the free navy
hoping that they would stop but
rightly argues that that is ridiculous
the free navy would never stop he tells
him about the railguns on the ring
station
asserting that they need to end the war
before they can worry about the future
and she knows she needs a belter ally we
talked about this earlier to improve
their chances and she would like holden
to
arrange a meeting with a drummer
so uh what did you think about this move
by vasrell
well i just wanted to say first that the
i i thought that was that was great how
the lucky earther
story you know it's doing good of course
he's you know getting death threats but
that's to be expected you know
it's nothing it's just changed over the
centuries right it's
of course if he's getting attention
somebody wants to kill him for for
working with the other side
but yeah i mean holden sounds ridiculous
here but he's really not wrong either i
mean
it i don't know how much you need to say
about it because the rail guns him
finding out about the rail guns changes
the focus
but his fears are valid and i
i liked the line that she threw out
there saying we can't afford the luxury
of worrying about the future until we
end this war
it's another thing that just shows that
this is these are extreme times and and
it's they kind of referenced that
whenever they were talking about
joseph's arm too they said oh we in
normal time we'd be able to do it like
this but this isn't normal time
and yeah it's all it all comes down to
the fact that they need drummer strength
they they
there's
it's not
something that they can the inners can
do by themselves
i don't know i mean like i said i think
that
it sounds ridiculous what holden's
saying i don't think that it necessarily
would work but
that is a real threat that isn't isn't
going to go anywhere you know people are
gonna they can't they can't just
allow
that to happen you know what i mean they
have to figure out something right yeah
i mean i i get that but you know
i get i get that the idea scenario would
be humanity coming together
and dealing with the real threat what
appears to be the real threat
but uh i think holden knows too
this just isn't gonna work
yeah he does i mean he is i i don't
think that
i doubt that he felt like
confused or surprised by the by her
response i like i said though it kind of
all gets
brushed aside when they learn about when
he learns about the railguns because
that is the the the the problem that
they have right now and then we also got
christian talking about how
belters see her because of you know she
she talks back about the
about hanging the belter on hooks the
scene that we know about from season one
what did you think about this
do you see real evolution in this
character because i mean she's the kind
of character that
can talk you know can make you think
that
she's doing what she what you want you
know what you want or what you need and
i think she's probably
uh
she's probably being sincere here
yeah she's changed a lot especially you
know after the asteroid attacks
after that disaster
um
she understands now that uh her
her past ways
isn't gonna help solve anything if
if anything that's gonna think that's
gonna make things worse as they did
and
um
she's definitely right to worry
that the belters wouldn't see her in a
good light
but i do agree she's changed we know
that but the belters have no way of
knowing that and drummer definitely says
you know you know what happens to
belters that trust dinners
she says that later in the episode so
the belters have no idea to know if
she's really changed so she's right to
be worried
yeah and she did lose a lot i mean she
lost her husband she lost her son before
that
and she's losing the planet that
that's kind of in the back of the you
know on the back of the list or the back
of the you know the bottom of the list
right now but
the planet is dying i mean she does
reference prax's thing looks promising
here and that that's probably going to
help but
she's got she's got a lot of things to
worry about
and a lot of and that's that's all
motivation to
actually do things differently going
forward
yup um we'll get to that but uh we have
a scene featuring amy zambabi they come
across each other on series and amos is
clearly drunk this this just amos's
whole attitude here was absolutely
brilliant
he opens up to bobby telling her that he
might not come back because of what
holden did so now bobby knows about
holden's decision too
bobby says that in the end the only
thing that matters is fighting for who
is covering your flank
doesn't matter if they're saints or
[ __ ] they're your people
they watch your back and you watch
theirs or you've got nothing
uh this makes sense to amos and
he will return to his family on the ship
but first he's gonna visit the brothel
brothel once again he even invites bobby
to join him and
this really this really made me smile
because we talked about this on almost
all of our streams i thought
they were kind of flirting with each
other and
but amos i don't know if he did this
because he was drunk but
he definitely didn't hide his intentions
bobby considers this but she doesn't go
and i'm wondering what you thought about
how bobby convinced amos
and
amos's invitation
yeah yeah i
i just i mean i wanted to i just when we
were when i was looking at this right
now i just wanted to
draw attention to this how how
how much is going on on this episode i
was just talking about with the todayo
thing how that still managed to
hit even though there's all these other
heavier moments and
this one is too but it has that
light-hearted
side of it because of the situation
because of the way it's set up
like i really loved how he said at the
beginning of this she she says something
about so you're just drinking and
[ __ ] or whatever and he says
until they run out of one or the other
and i also liked how he
he dropped the cap
when he was opening the bottle and he
didn't even bother to pick it up because
he knows he's going to finish it he
doesn't need the top you know what i
mean like it's just going to
it's completely this bottle is open and
it's going to be consumed and
that's it
you know he's got he's got his path laid
out in front of him
and i think that it was a really
you know like i said this this this
episode manages to do so many things and
i think it's all a good counterweight to
the actual like there's a lot of
exposition that needs to be
doled out as far as setting up where
everything's at as far as the finale
right like we had to learn about how
this railgun works how
his plan is
set up how they have to you know i mean
there's a there's just a lot to that
that they had to
sort of give us like holding talking
about the the the ships and then lb
talking about what's going on there you
know there's a lot of of stuff that's
just details that are necessary to
move forward and then so you have the
this balance of
these kinds of scenes where we get
we get the solution to amos's problem
his problem is that he doesn't know what
he
why he's there anymore
because the the six months of chasing
down ships
that wore the whole crew down and
when they get a chance to
finish the fight
his captain does something he can't
understand and
so i thought it was pretty
excellent that bobby laughs it off when
she when she finally learned she's the
last person to learn that
holden disabled the nuke
and then also amos the way he was
calculating things out
on the one hand he's you know he says i
think that he's trying to get us killed
and on the other he saved the entire
human race a couple of times
so it all balances
out but you know it's it it really sets
the idea
of what they get to it really drives
that home right
it's why they fight that's what that's
where the the the episode title comes
from and it's sort of what everyone's
dealing with in their different way and
you know they're they're his people
that's his family you know that's that
you you fight for them because they they
they have they fight for you and and
what else is there you know if you're
not if you're not with them then what
are you doing
of course they make mistakes and they do
things
but that's you know
that's because they're humans you know
what i mean so
man i think
this this is a great segue to um our
next subject because
joseph has his new army move that
mitchell reveals to drummer that she'll
stay on series with joseph the drummer
has lost her
entire family one by one
three of them
i think two of them separated last
season one of them died
two of them are separating again at
least until this war ends and now
drummer is all alone
so on the one hand we see you know aims
deciding to stay with his family but on
the other hand
another family
gets separated
yeah
and i just want to i just want to pause
on that for a second because i pulled up
this super chat a while ago and we
haven't we haven't spoke about it yet
but
again thank you tm martin for the five
dollars do you think holden's this
disarmed nuke will play a key role in
the series finale
and ps
where is walker we didn't actually see
walker in this episode at all huh he
he's over on his ship and they didn't
really show it
yeah maybe he he doesn't really trust
the inners as much as uh drummer
yeah
he's not taking them at their word
and he definitely suits his character
well he he he's he's a known he's a
known member of the free navy and now
that now that i think about it so
he may have to hide out in this
situation it may not be safe for him
exactly he might find himself on the
wrong end of an interrogation if he
makes himself uh known his presence
known
what do you think about this disarmed
nuke i they i obviously can't really
speculate because i already know what's
going to happen but i do see a lot of
people wondering if that's going to come
in and we talked about this a little bit
last week i mean the main thing
i thought when it was first introduced
you know them discovering this was that
it was playing the role of
planting a seed of doubt in philip's
mind about whether his mother was the
one that disabled it or not if she was
looking out for him
in that time
what did you what was your
where are you at on that right now
yeah i think i said um
this is not going to play an important
role you know some people are
speculating that
this is this ship this nuke sorry is
going to be used to destroy something
crucial
but i don't think it's going to play an
important role like that
they're definitely reusing the gate
reusing the nuke on the pela but
i don't i don't think it's that
important in terms of the actual nuke
itself like i said it has more of a
sentimental
more more of an emotional impact on
as to how it impacts philip and
his decision-making because he knows
someone on the rossi disabled it
i think i think they're going to focus
on that part
rather than a material object
so yeah
yeah so that yeah i think that we're on
in the same place with that then
yeah exactly so okay so we were talking
about
um about
the loss of of family yeah and i mean
it's it's just it just keeps coming for
drummer right he lost his arm and she
lost them
and this is like you said is the last of
her family they're all gone now she's
she's
it's a it's a terrible setup for naomi
to ask her to meet her family later
isn't it
exactly and you know there's
there's this idea that she loved them
because they were builders and you think
well
that's cool but they they
you know they decided to
get involved in this and and they didn't
really right you know
she wasn't trying to be a fighter either
she she
left
she had a position
an important role in fred johnson's opa
and she left and decided that she didn't
want to be
involved with any of this stuff
and she got sucked back in and
but yeah it's just it's it's pretty
tragic i mean she
she just keeps managing to get pulled
back into things and
her family is pays the price not her you
know what i mean
and yeah on this subject
mw says shouldn't someone properly
acknowledge and or help drummer for
saving the rossi by sacrificing
everything feels glossed over
what am i missing he says
he's talking about season five here
right yeah
yeah yeah and i i think nothing i think
the the point
i think the point is that
they're they're
it's expected you know it's that nobody
is looking out for
the belt
i think that's the you know maybe that's
not a satisfying answer but i think that
that's sort of what it
it's one of the things that it's going
for you know
she
if you think about the situation
she's essentially
she's essentially a pirate working for
the free navy and then she does
in this one battle change sides
but
the rossi is an independent ship it's
not like she went in and
you know won a battle for the un or the
mcrn for them to actually
acknowledge it
it's it was a it was a it was a selfless
act of sacrifice and you know nobody
you saw that there was a message from
naomi
acknowledging it in the x-ray that
didn't even exist in the actual tv show
and i think that's the point is that
it's it's kind of
she's not prospering or gaining from
this this is something that she's doing
because
she feels like it's the right thing to
do in the moment
and there's a cost and and that's part
of the reason why she doesn't want to
join up with the inners because if she
helps them again
what happens what happens if abacirala
dies and somebody else comes into power
how are they going to treat the belters
you know what i mean it's just it's a
precarious situation that they find
themselves in at all times it's
a process of picking the lesser of two
evils
quite literally and yeah so it's a good
question
and you know
there's
there's not a satisfying answer because
it's a bad situation
all right uh before we get to drummond
drummer and naomi we see drummer walking
back to the ship
uh
her ship to be more exact she arrives at
a checkpoint and a soldier tells her she
can skip the line because she is pretty
cleared
and even though she wants to wait like
everyone else she is encouraged to do it
she passes sandrani here who takes the
video asking how it feels to be the
inner's favorite pet
and when drummer gets back to the titan
she finds naomi waiting for her
anything to say on this interaction
before me we move on pete i guess this
this place
yeah
i would just say that you know this is a
reminder of
how working with the inners would go
over like this is just hey look this is
what people are going to think of you if
you do
follow through with this idea
and it also is it makes it
it makes it plain it makes the idea that
they need to meet why they need to meet
out in the open and while they while
they need other people to witness what
they're saying in the open
why they need that later you know that's
where
i mean this is it's kind of felt like a
little out of the out of left field with
with sandrani but
it makes sense in that context you know
they have to
like they have to they have to make sure
you realize just what a decision that
it is i mean you think about like how
characters like
um
like say miller in season one how he's
considered an enemy to his people this
is the same kind of stuff that the
drummers right on the cusp i mean she
just brought she just saved everyone on
series
but that that's not enough to
insulate her from the idea of her
working with the inners you know what i
mean
i think that's where coming from saint
jorani is is is why that actually works
because
we saw the same kind of situation you
know she she had the chance to
change sides
they changed you know they had the
chance to change sides and and didn't so
let's look at this uh
christina gave us a 499 super chat
and before so before we move on to the
the thing with the drummer and naomi
let's talk about amos she wants to know
what's up with him
book amos was never so blase about naomi
or jim's emotional turmoil
i was shook he just he considered not
going back
yeah i think what you see going on with
amos here in this episode or this season
of the show is that
he's starting to he's starting to think
about making his own decisions the thing
about the thing about amos and i i know
that you know this already christina
because
you've read the books but
he you know he uses people as his moral
compass he thinks about like how would
this person do something
so
in this particular situation
he can't really square it and he doesn't
have anyone else to do he doesn't have
anyone else to take on you know
clarissa kind of uses him in this same
way
so it's not like he can say well what
would clarissa do in this situation and
so you know it kind of undermined his
whole process whenever holden made this
decision that he just can't square
so yeah it felt a little bit strange i
agree that it it felt a little unamiss
some of the stuff that happened in the
first three episodes
or the you know
but i thought that they did a good job
of bringing it back
and then finishing it off here because
now you know at the end of this
conversation with bobby
that he's square
like he's he's he's 100 back on board
we know he's loyal to
maybe to a fault and you know that's
that's
everything is is back in in line and i
think it's i thought it was
it was a little bit of a change but i
think it worked out pretty well i i i
kind of like it
yeah from a number creator perspective
i i think his reactions this season have
been
they've all made the sense
i don't i don't know about the changes
they've made but
his interactions with holden and this
conversation here with bobby they all
seemed natural
yeah and and we have another one here
before before we move on
uh robin b thought that elvie died in
the orange on the i believe she's
talking about the bullet
when we last saw her but she showed back
up in this past episode
did the
orange
aka the bullet not kill her
no
it it didn't it didn't kill her um
she passed through it to
destroy the proto-miller
that was his plan and he needed help to
actually again he needed someone in the
substrate to help him
pass through
the bullet the artifact from the unknown
aggressors and
it didn't it didn't kill her
she's not really she's not really sure
what she experienced in there there they
haven't really gotten into it too
heavily
but um
yeah she's all right she she stayed
there and she she studied the bullet for
a period of time and now she came back
through the rings and she's doing
something in the jupiter system
and she is a character that that plays
uh
future roles in the book seven eight and
nine so if you like the character that's
another reason to really jump into the
books because
elvie is great
do you have anything you want to add to
that
uh no but um
like like we said before we saw her
send a message to holden and because
fred johnson had the product molecule uh
sample and
alden was trying to i think warned him
about it and
alden showed johnston
a message from elvi okoye about these
unknown aggressors so we already knew
and she was alive
yeah we just
yeah if you wanna um if you go back if
you wanna see what that scene it's in
season five episode one
so you can go back and see her talking
about that her time um
to get to get refreshed on that if you
need to
uh yeah we clicked on that at the same
time
all right so melvin brennan thank you so
much for the ten dollars good stuff from
both of you question is there a single
more complete character arc in sci-fi
television than kamina drummer
i can think of one maybe gaius baltar
well i
i don't
i think as far as i mean it's
obviously it's subjective and it depends
on
the story but i i think in the expanse
television show
which you're talking about all of sci-fi
television your question
um
you know i i think that
specifically in the expanse there is not
a better one
there's a lot of there's a lot of really
good ones but i think hers is is is the
best i made a video about that
about a month ago
um and yeah and personally i can't think
of anyone
outside of that
not right now not right when we're in
the middle of watching this you know who
knows if you take some time and go back
and yeah what about what what i mean i
think right now i'm it's just
everything's working with her story and
she's such a good encapsulation of
the overall the overall theme of what's
going on with her people you know it's
it's really
they really did a good job of of
crafting that
i would add that
maybe spock and
admiral kirk
from star trek i think
they could definitely go head-to-head
with drummer
and there are obviously there are
obviously more characters but it's hard
to
immediately remember them before you
know looking at all the best sci-fi
shows out there it's hard to
remember all of them
right now
yeah i i i'd be interested to see what
people say in the comments about this
because yeah i
i think it's a
i think it's hard to come up with
someone that that has such a
well
rounded
complete kind of thing going in and you
know it's it's definitely cool it's
definitely a great a great character and
a great
uh journey that she's been on
let us know in the comments what you
guys think about this i mean i i no one
is even coming close whenever i'm going
through it
babylon 5 is yeah that's
that's definitely where you would look i
would think
[Music]
i don't know thanks for the question
i'll def if i can if somebody comes up
to and i'll definitely
fire that off
yeah and thank you charlie buck for the
five dollar super chat he doesn't say
anything but uh
did he follow that up with something
no i don't think so
i looked at the actual youtube chat as
well that that doesn't appear to be a
message
all right thanks charlie buck
okay it's time to talk about
drummer and naomi
naomi's claim that she's just here to
see her
um
isn't really drama isn't really buying
that she knows naomi must have an
ulterior motive and when she learns what
that motive is which is trying to
convince her to join forces with the
inners against marco
drummer just loses it and this is some
of the best acting we've seen on the
show by krg drummers bewilderment is
depicted so clearly that you immediately
understand you know what this means for
her
and what makes this worse for drummer is
that
she knows naomi is kind of right
she either waits for the bounty to go
high enough that someone will kill her
or she can put a collar around her neck
and hand the inners the leash those are
her words
there are no good options here
and at this point naomi says all we can
do is stand by the people we love what
else is there
a drummer drops multiple f-bombs calling
naomi a self-righteous [ __ ]
and she and she breaks down crying as
they embrace each other
i absolutely love this scene and it's
it's hard to make
make these dramatic scenes work if
if you haven't if you haven't set them
up correctly but like we like we were
saying before because of drummer's great
character arc throughout
all of these seasons
this scene really hits correctly
now what do you think
yeah this was
i mean this was the the the culmination
of so much setup you know it it felt
like
it was gonna be like
cathartic but it's the opposite right i
mean
i i don't know like i saw some people in
the chat earlier saying that
these two characters were boring and you
know that's an opinion you can have that
opinion if you want
um
but yeah i can't i just can't
say what the op how how much of the
opposite reaction to this that i had
when i first watched this and
like you so many things like it's you
could talk about this
for
i mean there's so many subtle things
that go back and forth here
one thing that stood out to me right
from the beginning and it was all down
to the performances both of them playing
off of each other but
carrichy whenever
her when her face drops whenever she
turns away like she
she really can't believe what she's
hearing it's almost beyond comprehension
this person that she cares for that she
trusts
comes into her house you know this ship
is her her house right and and says
hey i want to meet your family you know
great to see you and sorry it's been so
long and yeah her whole family's gone
but
she's there because
she's running an errand for the inners
you know what i mean for her boyfriend
who obviously
uh you know
drama doesn't care for she doesn't she
doesn't like holden
you know what i mean for multiple
reasons
yeah for so like it's just it's you can
just see it in in in the in the actor's
face that this is so beyond
comprehension that there's nothing else
that she can do except for turn away and
tell her to leave
and
that's just where it starts you know
what i mean like it goes through they
they cycle through so many different
things because
what can naomi actually say here you
know what i mean
she is
she is doing exactly what she's being
accused of
and naomi is is
is a smart character and
so yeah she knows that
she knows everything that she's done
leading up to this conversation
is fully on display and
it's really i mean
it's it's a
it's a bad place for both of them
because
still need to talk about this it still
needs to happen you know what i mean
drummer has lost everything
and that's not going to change nobody
can bring any of it back for her
and name the only thing naomi can do is
say look i get it but
marco's gonna win
and we need your help
and it's not even me you know it's it's
abisarala the the secretary general of
the un
so it's just it's just super heavy stuff
christina jay
added do you think naomi will confess to
christian her crimes or repay drummer
by facilitating things
things and
quotations and amends
um
so
what do you think naomi will confess to
christian her crimes or repay drummer by
facilitating things in amends what's
your take on this
uh
i don't really
i don't really get the question to be
honest
do you
i'm having a little bit of trouble with
it um
i think
the crimes part is what's throwing me
off
we have some clarification on this
christina
yeah i think i think that i mean
i think naomi has a little bit of pull
if that's what the question is of if she
can do something
or
um
but
i'm not sure
i'm not sure if there's if that's really
going to make a difference at this
conjuncture i mean
like i was saying
the real problem here is that drummer's
lost everything and
she doesn't have another option but to
help
i mean isn't that isn't isn't that the
big takeaway here is that
even though it's a thankless situation
to be in
and that she probably won't get anything
out of it what else can she do
yeah and she doesn't even have her
family to care for in the in the ship so
i think i think that kind of helps
because she's not going to be putting
joseph and michio in danger by
joining forces
with the inners
maybe if they were on the ship she
wouldn't do this
but because they're they're not there
anymore
i think that's one of the reasons
she goes on to agree
to this deal
yeah i i and and christina she just uh
he just clarified a little bit
i think um
i think that they they didn't i think
that if there's one thing that's missing
from this equation it might be that
they don't really show how they get to
the point where
odin's able to talk naomi into doing
this thing because this is a pretty
awful thing that she's doing
she's coming there
with
actual care in her heart for this person
but she's she's she's making them a
and making them a
a a a proposition that
she knows is a bad deal right
exactly and
she knows this goes against everything
drummer stands for
she knows how the drama is going to
react and even then
she knows she has to do this because
paulden asked them to and it makes sense
because
they're not gonna they're probably not
gonna defeat marco
without her help
yeah so so you know from from a logical
perspective naomi's doing the right
thing but
obviously from an emotional standpoint
this this sucks both for her
and obviously even more for drummer
yeah and i liked how she i liked how she
she she told her you know like he said
she
self-righteous [ __ ] and
it was it was a it was an echo of her
talking with
oksana at the end of last season when
she was telling her you know like how
much [ __ ] do i have to eat before
you believe me and which you know that
we know how that turned out you know
what i mean so
it i just thought yeah this was the the
the the the apex of
the emotion that that this was i mean if
you have these two performers i mean
and you and you're writing a season of
tv you have to figure out how to make
this scene happen right
and
this this is
the way that they put it together and
the fact that neither one of them has a
leg to stand on
neither one of them is trying to hurt
the other person but everybody is
getting hurt and there's nowhere else to
go and there's nothing
either one of them can do about it i
mean she says it in that line i don't
feel like there's a place for me in this
universe
and
yeah it's just it's just fantastic and
then they break down briefly at the end
but it doesn't really change anything
and you know it's all under that same
thing why we fight right you know fight
for the people you love in this case
fighting for the person that drummer
loves
has cost her her family and it's gonna
cost her more going forward
and she's still gonna have to do it
anyways because there's really no other
option
because of the way things played out
so it's a perfect example of
the belter situation
and it's great to see these two belter
characters have that
and see that play out
yeah i i think christina
clarified here
okay things you probably can't touch but
yeah naomi forcing chrissy to do right
by kamina
it would be nice if she had that combo
instead yeah okay so yeah i agree with
that and
like i said if there's one thing that
that didn't get set up as well was that
we didn't see how naomi got convinced to
do this we saw holden push back briefly
saying you know she's not going to trust
you and then we jumped straight to
naomi showing up unannounced knowing
that she didn't want to see her
right and being there so
it's pretty messed up and
i think
there's a trust issue anyways underneath
that
abisarala can tell her anything but how
do they know they're going to hold her
to it and what happens if if abba sarah
is not in charge anymore
it's still
tricky all the way around but yeah i
agree that it would have been it would
have been helpful to see
or it would be nice to see her advocate
for that
to make sure that
because once once she does turn and help
the inners there's a certain percentage
of people that will never
see her the same way again she'll be a
traitor to her people on some level
yeah and that's
that's actually what i've been wondering
because
right now drama doesn't really control a
lot of ships i think it's not even 10
ships right but we've been hearing the
news about um
about certain stations
uh i guess
rioting against the free navy so
drummer joining forces with the inners
might
garner even more support because they're
going after marco
so she might control
more ships now
or like you said this could backfire and
the
belters big portion of the might turn
against her
that's something i'm looking forward to
see
in the finale if more ships join
drummer
yeah because they could lose too i mean
that's the reality
this side siding without the serala
doesn't mean you're going to win and get
what you want it could mean that you get
executed
by the free navy whenever they take over
the entire solar system
so there was before we get into the last
i mean we could talk and you know
we could talk about that one scene
and maybe we will come back and talk
about it some more but i think it i
think we need to move on to the next one
because it's so integral and what
everything we're saying is kind of
setting that up
but i wanted to
i saw there was one
super chat here that we missed and they
pavel barros thanks for the five
pounds and do you guys think they would
finish the story as an
animated series considering the time
jumping all
um i i don't think so
yeah i think it's a heart i i don't
think there's anything wrong with an
animated series i just think it's a hard
transition once you've had
so much live action
to
it's it feels like a step down and i
don't i don't say that in a way of like
i don't want to debate whether
animation is
is a fine way to do it or not it
certainly could be i just think that
once it's been introduced as live action
i think it feels like
when you have all of these great sets
that they had built and all these
amazing vfx sequences and everything
else
it's just hard to
it's hard for it to feel like the same
thing
yeah in that situation i would almost
think like you just start from the
beginning and you start an animation an
animated series that's unrelated to what
happened to the live act you know what i
mean it's just spinning off spin off
yeah yeah like a spin-off and it could
be they could just redo the entire
same trajectory as as what the tv show
did but just start from the beginning
and and introduce it to a brand new
audience and as a different different
version
i mean you could it it's not un
unthinkable but i just think that you
know
it feels pretty unlikely to me
agreed um i think we can move on to the
ending of the episode here
uh
this one ends with the meeting between
masarala and drummer as they join forces
against marco
but it is quite clear that there is no
love lost between them because
drummer still doesn't fully trust of
azerala
but the fact that wasralla shows up on
the station on series actually
helps her
image i suppose
there were so many great lines here so
i'm going to pass it over to you to
mention some of them and give us your
thoughts
yeah i think that
i think this was i mean i the the thing
that blew me away about this episode is
that
there's so many of you know what i mean
it's like
you you transition from
one of the heaviest interview
heaviest back and forth between two
characters and then to one of the most
sensational here with these two and
the way it's set up
the way she she moves through the
station and they come together and
the way it's been set up that they need
to do this out in the open they need to
do it in public
and like you said
she does win a lot of credibility by
coming out of her ship like she
she has a good security
security detail and everything else but
this is pretty crazy that she's just out
on a belter station
during an act of war
you know what i mean
it's it's pretty wild and
and there's already been an attack and
multiple explosions here
absolutely
that's really brave
and you know it and and there's there's
sympathizers for sure and you can't
really tell you know it's an insurgent
force that they're up against it's not
like you know
they're they're an occu they're
occupying the station
so yeah it's dangerous
it's dangerous for her to be out there
yeah we were talking we were talking
about how surprised we were
about the fact that you know her ship
was so close when they were taking over
uh series and then she actually
went on it
no this was really surprising
yeah that's one of those things like i
said when i watched earlier i was like
why is she actually so close to the
action that seems dangerous and then if
it's all just to be in service of this
scene happening then i'm basically okay
with it
it made for good tv
indeed especially you
know i think they
uh shook hands at the end if i'm if i'm
remembering remembering it correctly
that was a good moment as well
yeah i mean i think that i think the big
thing here is that
she says the system is filled with the
you know filled with the the graveyards
of you know it's a graveyard of belters
who trusted the inners and
avasarala fires back
that her planet's now covered with the
bodies of people who paid the price for
that
and this is uh you know that's a nice
parallel too because
avasarala is right a lot of people died
because of their actions the actions of
the powerful
but it's you know it's not absolutely
well actually you know she did pay for
it she lost her husband and her
and her son but i mean in general
a lot of people have suffered on both
sides and they can both make a a
decent
argument for that
and drummer is
correct in saying that this was all
started by the inners so
it's a great setup to
continue the idea that we talked about
this is not something that drummer wants
to do but it is something that's
actually necessary
tells her that marco is going to get a
lot more belters killed that's true
and she and she does need her and as
soon as that as soon as kamina
gives in and helps her then
less people will die so
it's it's i think it's also worth
mentioning this idea that she asked her
you know what are you gonna are you
gonna remember us after marco's dead and
she she can't say that she can only
promise that she'll try basically right
because she
what can she actually do and this kind
of goes back to christina's question
she's given them plenty of reasons to
hate her but none to think she's a liar
so it's enough at the end of the day and
like you said they shake hands
they form this union
and you know it's funny because if you
think about these kinds of things
historically
right it feels like oh good they're all
they're fighting on the same side
everything's good
i mean think about world war ii the the
soviet union in the united states
worked together
to
defeat a common enemy
it's not like they had great relations
for
the decades following that right so yeah
it's only a temporary this only a
temporary thing
and you know drummer doesn't really get
much out of this
extent except that it is
ultimately the right thing to do
yeah there is some you know slim upside
to this as well though because
if they do defeat
marco and
if the bel if the belters
are if drummer and her crew are really
useful in that in
adventure and if allah then goes on to
stay as the you know remain as the um
secretary general
this could make things better
for the belt because like wasseralla
said she's not a liar she's many things
but she's not a liar
she's always been straight
and
she sticks by her word
so there's this still impossibility that
the outcome of this war will actually be
good for the belt
i'm not sure if it's gonna really turn
out that way but
that's an interesting possibility
the drummer might be doing might be
doing the belt a favor here
and that is the i mean that's the that's
that's why this is brilliant too because
both of these characters they understand
that going in right
it's uh
there
there's a slim chance that things might
get better
but as
drummer pointed out in this conversation
just a few
sentences ago she said you know
historically speaking there are sis
there's there's there's a system there's
there's
forces that make sure that they always
they always lose out it never turns out
to to actually be helpful
there's generations of of experiences
and
cases where it didn't you know what i
mean so it's yeah
it's it's great and and
it is you know albusarala is obviously
powerful but
she's not magic she can't just she can't
just will it to be fixed afterwards and
it'll be done it's much more complicated
and messy right
exactly
and i also wanted to ask you about
something else um
do you also feel like you know the
pandemic has really
affected some of these um scenes this
one you know featured a lot of people so
i'm not talking about this scene in
particular but
you you mentioned this in your episode
recaps as well there are a lot of
scenes with just two people talking in a
room
those scenes are brilliant don't get me
wrong but
the the
i think
the the amount of scenes like that are
a little bit too much for my liking
even though like i said they're good did
you did you get that same impression
yeah i i definitely got that impression
when i first watched it i think that
it's it's kind of
on the re-watch and now that i was just
sort of adjusted it doesn't seem as as
apparent anymore
but this whole i i mentioned this in a
previous uh stream like the this whole
series thing
you could this kind of feels
a lot different than season one series
and you can and you see how they kind of
built this
out of shipping containers in a way that
they can multi-purpose different areas
and use them for different things but
still kind of have a bit of a crowd but
because it's smaller in general it seems
a little bit more
crowded because of
being a smaller smaller set i thought
you know if you look at the if you look
at the season one series things i mean
it feels like it's a whole
there's a whole multi-layer
world that's been built there and and
here this this kind of feels i mean i
guess this is just specifically the
docks but even in that way
you know the the bar that they drink at
and stuff it all felt like it was
it was
kind of scaled down so that they could
have less people and make it look more
crowded
for that pen for the pandemic
yeah and i'm hoping that if if the show
returns or if we get movies you know
they they're able to go back to what we
saw
in the earlier seasons
yeah i i think they did a pretty good
job i i i think you know i think that
they
i think it mostly works but it's
noticeable that they change their style
up and i feel like that that is
a um you know that's that's a result of
restrictions that that were outside of
their control
uh we've got a question here we can
answer lighter mam asks pete benjamin do
you think
or can you say if the u.n treats the
belters well 30 years on
i don't think you can answer this one
because you read the book speed
yeah i can't answer i mean it would be a
it would be an actual spoiler yeah uh
in my opinion
uh
things might be
ah this one's this one's i think i think
they're going to be treated better but
like like of us said you know sorry like
a character said it i can't remember
which one it was that said we're all
belters now
and i think that situation
the fact that earth was attacked and it
is not the same anymore
um maybe the belters aren't going to be
treated a bit
in a better way but
everybody
everybody's like a belter now
the system is looks like it's crumbling
and uh
i i don't think the the oppression will
be the same
30 years from now
that's that's right
yeah and i think that's an interesting
um idea that
the way you draw on that they're more
likely to
treat them well whenever they're in a
situation when they're on their back
foot when they are
actually more
like belters
you know
yeah that
when they're when they when they're not
completely dominant in the situation
but you never know you don't know what's
going to happen and
i think although that depends on the
finale right yeah
yeah
it does
and guys you can answer your you can ask
your questions in the chat now because
we're almost done with the episode recap
i think we can answer a few of your
questions
yeah absolutely well
what did you think about this episode
overall pete um
since we're done with all of the plot
points
do you think we are ready for the finale
yeah i i thought i
i mean i i had a general idea of how the
story would would play out anyways from
reading the book
and
i think that i felt pretty good when i
got to this end of this episode
the one thing that i thought
i thought i think what's i thought this
was a fantastic episode one of the best
episodes
overall
i thought that
it was it was a little bit
it was crazy how
how much
drummer's story had to turn in in in
like
such a short amount of time but i think
they pulled that off
you know where she's at at the beginning
compared to where she's at to make the
deal at the end i think it worked
the part that i guess whenever i thought
about the overall story is that we don't
have an idea of where they go from here
yet we know that there is an actual
conclusion coming
in the next episode which is only 63
minutes long which is much longer than a
normal one but
it's it's not
there's not multiple hours left anymore
there's one hour so i think that's where
i was kind of like well how are they
gonna how they gonna transition into
the final
confrontation kind of thing right
so i uh but otherwise i mean like
there's so much going on in this episode
and
there's no weak spots there's really no
it all is really working all the way
across and like we mentioned there's
funny there's there's a little bit of
comedy to lighten things up there's some
there's some heartfelt
character moments they're not all
completely end of the world
horrors of war type stuff you know what
i mean so and
i think that's that's really realistic
and that's the way it should be done
because if we get action all the time
what is the point if you don't get to
know the characters that are
in the action
if you don't care for them if we don't
know their backstories and what's the
point
so they're doing yeah and they're doing
a great job of you know setting us
setting it up and making us care about
all of these characters and how they
interact with each other
you know
the
this deal between amazon and drummer is
a great example of that
yeah and i i was listening to the key
interview on the on the podcast when she
was you know she said she would describe
this show because avasarala says you
know she was talk uh
you know that actor was talking about
how
why did why did they do sci-fi because
it's such great character stuff and you
know it's
basically because of the time period
right and
krg was saying that when she would tell
her friends that she would call it
political
political and it's you know political
intrigue but with spaceships
and i think that you know they
they got to they really got there they
really hit that note right before the
finale right the everything
everything
led to this moment and it all makes
sense and it all and it does it makes
you care so much more about everything
that that's going into that
and you know it maybe that's not for
everyone i i you know i get plenty i
read plenty of comments all the time and
and some people
have an idea that this season has
nothing's happened and
i'd say yeah that's just it's probably
not your cup of tea then this show
because
everything that needed to happen is
happening
i guess like i said my one my one fear
at this point was
how do they transition into everything
that has to
conclude you know we that's what we have
to wait and see
yeah and we can continue with another
question this time from charlie buck he
asks what has been your least favorite
departure from the books
um i haven't read the books but i know
that um alex was still supposed to be
here
i think uh the unfortunate situation
with that one
is my least favorite departure
what about you pete
yeah um
i mean that was not something that they
made a choice to do that that's
something that had to happen i i think
in the in the
in the first
book
i didn't like i didn't like how the the
crew started out being at odds with each
other
in the tv show
and there was a lot of tension that was
sort of added it makes sense on why they
did it in the adaptation but
i just i just enjoyed the story better
without that when i read the book
i read the book after the show and i
thought wow this i like the way this is
a lot better but
i think that's probably the biggest
thing and and it comes up in other parts
um
naomi giving the
giving fred johnson
the proto-molecule
rather than holding given it to them
that that kind of
i i i don't really like the way that
that has was received
and and in in
and it's only in comparison to what the
way it plays out in the books you know
what i mean i don't think it's bad
i just think i liked it better whenever
they didn't have that thing
and it made for
you know you can see why they did it in
the show and it does work
it creates a conflict that easy easy but
that's what it felt like in the show to
me it felt like conflict for the sake of
conflict
yeah you know
um
angel
feisler asks sorry if i butchered your
last name uh she wants us to give our
thoughts about the x-ray which
uh he or she loved
uh we talked about this at the start of
our stream i think yeah you can watch
the vod we
i think we talked about it for 10 to 15
minutes you know we both loved it
and there was a [ __ ] and yet
definitely go back and watch that
because um
i thought there i thought that it was it
was really effective at bringing the
story full circle and i don't want to
since a lot of the people have been here
already saw that i don't want to go into
it again but
it's a good question and i agree with
you it was very it was i loved it too
i'm high up on the chat um pete can you
bring up the latest superset yeah
thank you
justin merritt thank you for the five
dollars it's a departure from the books
but i would be pleased to see amos and
bobby hook up it makes sense for the
characters
um
sure i i saw that
i saw that
you know they ty ty made a comment about
this
on twitter about they wanted to
they were more interested in i think my
interpretation of what he said i'm
paraphrasing but
my interpretation was that they wanted
to play with that
uncomfortable
you know kind of just
play with it more than they actually
wanted to to have it
go anywhere
you know that tension there's there's
obvious sexual tension
and then to kind of toy with that some
you know what i mean so
i i don't know it's
it's hard for me to say if it makes
sense for the characters because
it would change things later and and
those are things that i've already
envisioned in the way that they
happened you know what i mean yeah and
because i don't have that knowledge for
me
it works quite easily i'll say this i'll
say this that it the thing that would
would be troubling for me is that amos
kind of makes it explicit that he
doesn't have sex with people he likes
right
like he goes to brothels and he he
almost exclusively sleeps with sex
workers that's what that's where he's
comfortable
and
you know that's a part of who he is so
if
it would be
it would be a it would be a
evolution of the character i think you
know not just that he would be with
somebody different but him getting with
someone that he's so closely related
with as far as
you know she's not really a crew member
at this point or anything but
it would make it would make it would be
it would be the departure from from what
he normally does
but i it would be fan it would be a
favorite i'm sure there's fanfiction
already out there written about that
right
exactly but let's not get into that
yeah
uh i think
we can quickly answer this one before we
check out the other super chats
herbert bolanos asks are you looking
forward to the expanse video game from
telltale games and yes i'm very much
looking forward to it i love all of
their games maybe we talked about this
in other streams as well
the their batman series and the walking
dead ones are great
yeah i've never i've never i don't play
games and i will definitely play that
one so that's that's what i can say
about it
uh we had two other super chat speeds
yep
naomi was given much more agency thanks
again christina for christina jay for
the 499 and the show but always seemed
to be the instigator of conflict
amos didn't even sneak peaches on board
miss the crew love
yeah it's
it's not really cut and dry you know
like i've heard people make pretty good
arguments for liking show naomi better
and the and and it's exactly what
christina is saying here about that
she feels
she kind of has she's kind of in a place
of
being a victim i think in the books it
it it's not
it's complicated obviously but
there are some things that i like that
they did but
i think i think that
generally
she is more likeable in some some
situations
and maybe maybe she's a little bit too
too competent in the books like maybe
you want to make her a little bit more
flawed because she's pretty badass all
the way around that you know i mean she
she's she's the she's the voice of
reason she's the
she's really good engineer she figures
out a lot of things so you know there's
there's there's definitely an argument
to be made that she's kind of like
too
too
too powerful or too perfect in the books
but at the same time it you know it can
backfire if if she feels like because
she's she's the one belter on board in
the first place so if she's
always the one that does something
that kind of goes against everyone else
then it kind of makes it kind of
otherizes her you know what i mean so
it's it's it's a difficult i guess it's
it's kind of difficult to
find the sweet spot in that to where she
she's believable and i think they do i
think they pulled it off
but there's a lot of people that like
this key up on that idea of her giving
the proto-molecule to fred johnson
as a reason to
to dislike the character
what um this other one doesn't have any
uh yeah another one without the title i
think they wanted did they just they
just wanted to show their sport
yeah i was just i was just sorry i was
just scrolling through to see if there
was a follow-up to it but yeah thank you
this shoe chin for the five dollars
uh we have another question here
are you going to bring the super chat up
or should i read
this let's do that real quick thanks
uh tian martin asks if you had a chance
to do a welcome roll
uh who why would you play or who i guess
um
this one is difficult to answer but i
would definitely want to be a martian
i always really like them the most yeah
especially you know
dusty
yeah
and
i i always kind of wish they showed more
of them but
i i was glad with with what we've got so
far i guess well now you can now you can
upgrade to laconia
oh true
maybe we'll see how that turns out
maybe that's maybe there's a future in
that for you
i would be a i would be a belter for
sure they're the most interesting they
live in space
but i mean you know that that one of the
things that is is is fun about the show
is that they all have their own unique
thing about them that that makes them
you know the that
the solidarity of martians you know it
kind of turned into a militaristic
um you know
extreme
but
you know the actual solidarity of
working on a generation's project of
building something together is is
obviously pretty cool i guess i like
them because they're they're similar to
the spartans and i've always liked them
they remind me of spartan so that's why
i like the martians a lot
you know not these not not really easy
to compare those but um
the um
i guess
the warrior culture
is a little bit similar
yeah
this this one here it says i wish they
showed the political sides of mars like
with earth i think we lost the last link
with mars
important ones in this episode
yeah there
a lot of the stuff with mars happens off
screen
i think they did a pretty good job of
bringing it back you know
through bobby and and
alex
i think that i mean that's such a key
role that's that's a key
factor in how everything plays out how
we got to this place that we're at right
now
so it would be it would be interesting
to see more of that
i guess though you know when they're
writing that they they kind of knew
where they were going with laconia
and and we get
we're getting a little bit of that
through strange dogs and
and then you know you get a whole lot
more of that
in the books that come after book six
uh she draws i really
i really like how i really like how the
the collapse of mars and the in the in
the in the way that they're what they're
doing their project loses its relevance
how that creates that situation where
you know
marco and
duarte can
can rise up in the vacuum and
how they how duarte especially
twist that idea that dream of mars
and you know we've only seen a little
bit of them in the tv show but you can
see that
you know he he's pretty
he's pretty good at talking to people in
that same way that
that
marco is is good at talking to groups of
people
sidrow c says how would you have felt if
they replaced alex character with new
actor
i thought that it might be a bad idea
just because uh
we already had five seasons with the
same same guy i mean you know they
switched abba sorella's husband and
it was weird and he's kind of a
secondary character
what do you think about this
uh yeah just too many seasons uh
if if if it was a more minor character i
would be fine with replacing him but uh
you know hard to swallow that change
after after five seasons
it just it would just look really
awkward
at least now you know they they mention
them sometimes but um
his his story had a at a um
reasonable conclusion i think
especially for normal readers but um
so you know i think replacing him would
be a little bit
cheesy
yeah and i think i think they i think
they they didn't really have a lot of
good options but i think they did
what they could
it would be super weird if we just had
some rando even if it was a really good
rando it would feel like
a rando in in the pilot's chair you know
and
i think it would it would
it wouldn't it wouldn't be as seamless
as it sounds like it could be but
you know it's
like you said it they gave him a pretty
they gave him a pretty heroic ending and
i i really think i really like the the
the
the scene with amos at the end of the
season whenever he's talking to naomi
about it
he talks about that going out for the
you know going out for the people that
you care about you know it's it's
actually a really nice
it really ties in nicely with what his
epiphany in this episode right amos's
epiphany in this episode that that is
what matters
so i think they just i think that's you
know they just did the best they could
and
i would i would i i was against the um i
was against the idea of recast
we got another chapter from
just a match yeah thanks
thanks again for the the five dollars as
we near the end i think their choices
for the show
and how much they had to cut change all
make sense i think that's what you're
saying is and they've done an excellent
job in season six and
yeah i i think um
again i think this is doing the best
with a bad situation i think that it
could have been better if it was eight
maybe even ten episodes
or if they just had
you know a little bit more time in each
epi each of the six episodes to let some
things breathe or develop things a
little bit more but i think they have
done a fantastic job i mean i was
nervous
as everyone whenever i heard it was six
gonna be six episodes and
i knew how much story there was left to
tell and thought that six sounded like
it would probably work but still wanted
it to be more anyways you know what i
mean because
there's so much good stuff that that's
possible that when they have a little
bit more time but
i think that they they they did it
pretty well i mean they
story wise they they had already moved
some stuff up
a lot of a lot of drummer stuff was
already moved up that that took up a lot
of of book six and then
they just made the whole rail gun thing
a mystery on
on uh
medina rather than
following
the installation and
how that all plays out in the part
before that so
i thought that worked i thought that
worked fine i don't think we really
needed to spend
more time on medina station to get the
same amount of understanding of what
happened there you know it might have
been fun but
i don't think it was necessary
yeah and
i think if they had more episodes and
i think they might have shown us a
little bit more uh
laconia stuff as well and i think that
would have made me
more invested in that story
so i think i think from from that from
that point of view
more episodes would have been a lot
better
about but the
but the other stuff you know the the war
between the free navy and the inners i
don't think that feels rushed to me but
like i said i haven't read the books
well from from from my perspective that
that stuff doesn't feel rushed at all
yeah and that's kind of the issue with
that's the kind of the issue with the
story and we talked about this in the
very first stream the structure
of this feels a lot different because
the
conclusion is pretty inevitable it's you
know it's a war
and you know it's going to come to an
end eventually
and everything kind of just
it it takes all the it takes all the
stuff on the side out of the picture
because everything everyone is tied into
this
thing that's all going in the same
direction so
i think a lot of why this season seems
different is more about story than it is
about how many episodes or or any of the
other stuff it's just that
there's a natural conclusion at the end
of this season and that's why it makes
sense that if you have to you can
stop it at the end of book six instead
of say like at the end of book five that
would be pretty awful
and and therefore
the story just moves in that direction
and there's nothing that you can there's
not too much that you can do on the side
to
prolong that
um
what else do we see here in the comments
i i'm not seeing any questions
that many questions
so what what were your thoughts about
the about this episode
uh it you asked me mine but yeah i i i
like the episode yeah i like the episode
on its own and what it sets up in the
finale
but i but i feel like this could have
been
maybe not the midway point of the season
well by episode
episode 7 or 18 in in a 10 episode
season maybe like we could have had two
or three more episodes after this that's
what it feels like to me the episode on
its own is great
all the character moments all the
interactions especially the naomi
drummer one
i absolutely love that
but um
to me it feels like um
i like i want at least two or three more
episodes after this
agreement between avocado and drummer
and it bumsy it bums me out that we're
only going to get 60 more minutes of
this
yeah
obviously
yeah i mean do you have
do you have
uh i've seen a lot of people that say
that same thing that you're saying and
then i see a lot of people saying
there's no way that they can wrap this
up in 63 minutes how how where are you
on the scale of whether you think they
can pull it off or not
i think
i think they can pull it off but uh
compare
now compared to how they did things
earlier this season and how
they did stuff in uh season five with
marco
the finale might feel rushed
because
they've intentionally
they've intentionally slowed things down
you know to have to give characters
these moments
so
the finale itself the big battle
that that one might be that might feel a
little bit rushed
that's that's what i fear at this moment
i don't think it's gonna suck or
anything
but
when when i just go back and
watch the rest of season five or
the start of season six
i feel like the finale will be
will feel a lot quicker than those parts
yeah it's
you know
not much that you can do about that
i i i get the i get the sentiment
and it's one that a lot of people have
but i i you know
obviously i already watched it and i
think that
most people will be
there's going to be a certain percentage
of people that are upset because
they don't realize that it's just the
end of book six it's not the end of the
bigger story
there's gonna be a percentage of people
that
like uh all of us that are just upset
because it's over
so they're gonna look at it more
critically than
what it you know
then what's realistic i think and then
otherwise i think it's
you know it's it's pretty satisfying and
they did a pretty good job and i don't
want to give anything away but i think
that
it'll be generally regarded as
a good series finale
with people detracting for those reasons
that i just mentioned
uh justin asked again he said what did
they cut that you wish you could have
seen for me it was anderson dawes
playing all the factions on tycho yeah i
was really disappointed that anderson
dawes died off screen
i was really kind of confused in the
last season whenever fred johnson died
because i liked his
i liked his his the stuff that he did in
season five or in season book six
and so i was wondering how they were
going to do that and they kind of
just didn't you know and
i i missed that i do miss the the
anderson dolls
and how that played out with the
the rest of the belt
we see that with with drummer but she's
kind of solo you know what i mean just
she just brought this guy walker in and
that you know they're in the books there
is some resistance amongst belters with
power that don't want to side with the
inners but
but aren't interested in working with
marco either
for political reasons
just quickly answering this
akcd11r 2012 asks is karina still alive
no she's way priced
yeah so dead i think is the way that you
would describe that
i mean i don't know
i mean she's in a suit
she might still be out there floating
somewhere
pavel baroche asks do you think the show
does a good job of explaining
uh the product molecule and what it
actually is
to
non-readers
um
i
i think you know
they've done a pretty good job in
especially in the earlier seasons but
that's that's kind of the point of the
product molecule mystery they don't have
to do
they don't have to explain it a lot
because it is the mystery
they have to give us bits and pieces
here and there
and i think they've done that
really well
but
the fact that it slowed down over the
course of um these last couple of
seasons definitely
bums me out
yeah but i don't know
there's a lot to what you're saying
there but it's supposed to be mysterious
that that's always supposed to be
mysterious
that that's part of why it draw it
drives the action the way that it does
is because no one really understands it
so as readers we don't really need to or
viewers in this case we don't really
need to understand it either we want to
and that and and that's why it's
compelling
i think the show did a reasonable
um you know for the for where we're at
in the story they don't really make a
lot of things explicit like with
characters saying them out loud about
like
you know the the protomolecule
is the way of building roads for this
other civilization like they don't
really get that specific in in
describing it and understanding it until
about the seventh book uh in the in the
books
so you really shouldn't
you're supposed to have questions about
it
and what it does and and
so i think they did a pretty good job i
think that they it's just uh
the way they structured the story
there's the unfortunate
reality that they have to
you know that the ring gates what it
does what the protomolecule does is open
the ring gates and that changes things
in the solar system so that causes a
conflict that they have to
move past in books five and six before
they can
before it becomes relevant again you
know
that's just that's just the story is
longer than what they have to work with
on the show that's the big problem i
think
yeah that makes sense
how about holden losing important
influence in season six versus book six
the belter stories forming coalition
yeah um
so this is he's talking about these
videos that that monica is making that
was something that
holden was doing and that does relate
david exactly to what i was just talking
about with fred johnson and that start
that part of the story being cut
without fred being there not having
someone who's
moderate opa you know someone who's
willing to work with the inners when
they have to
you know
that's what we're missing there so he
you know holden couldn't really do that
in in this he's been flying around in
the ship
killing belters
you know what i mean
that's been his mission for six months
since since the end of last season was
to go and
literally kill
free navy partisans
what do i think about him losing his
important influence i mean i think that
holden is is i don't think he he
i think we all know who the character
holden is and what he believes and and
and what side he lands on in that so i
don't i don't think he really lost any
influence or any credibility it's just
that
in the show they made it a lot more of a
point that he disabled those that he i
mean he did that in the in the story and
in in the books he also didn't he wasn't
in charge of much of anything
in that battle
because he had fred johnson and his crew
on board so
it's sort of a trade-off
but i think that i don't think he's
really lost any anything overall he's
he's just uh
he's just doing some different things
because of how the structure of where
everyone's at is a little bit different
uh valk volky volk volkman asks do you
think there's enough material in the
books to create a spin-off episode
maybe uh he wanted to say spin-off
series because he says similar to balak
better start like the razer
what could it be about he asks
uh i'm not really from are you familiar
with razer
i think um did is this the one that had
only one season and got cancelled
i know i think that's something
different yeah oh that that's the that's
the planet that got annihilated wasn't
razer
a mini movie then
i i guess
you know could they do a mini movie like
a spin-off
they could do um
no i mean
nothing that's nothing that's
substantial they could do a lot of they
could do a lot of the stories and
in the rings after the fact there's a
couple of novellas that
they kind of go there i think it would
be
difficult to
do anything
caprica that's what that's the that was
the series that they had that's what i
was thinking of when i read razer at
first
um
i think if they were going to do a
spin-off series that didn't involve the
crew of the rossi then you could do it
on
laconia um you could you could you could
make you know there's obviously
something going on there you could have
uh people on that side of the story see
it from their perspective
um
strange dogs is a novella that exists
there there's a couple of other ones as
well
you could have any number of things in
in
it's hard it's hard to say without
talking about what happens in the finale
but you could have a
there's definitely branches that you
could go on and and tell compelling
stories inside this universe
one of the issues is though that i don't
think that tai and daniel have any
interest in writing those
you know
that would be something where they'd
bring new guys in and
they'd be making something that didn't
exist up which could still be good
because it's a nice world they did a lot
of work in building this world up so
it's ready to move in they but they
would have to you know they'd have to
put it in someone else's hands i suppose
this is where we can bring up um
the the video game again
it's not going to be
in the present time i think it's gonna
be about drummer's past when she was a
pirate
so you know they're doing some stories
like spin-offs but
they might not be movies or
tv shows they might come in the form of
um
video games if if this one is successful
if the first one is successful
yeah that yeah there's a there's a ton
if you go backwards i know that they i
know that i've read things that ty and
daniel are especially opposed to
prequels
and being involved
and that involves prequels but
i think they i think they probably
consulted on the game either way so you
know it's they they sold the rights you
know that
alcon owns the um
the ip
this quasi misu says um oberon the
spelling's a little bit off here but
oberon is what i was thinking of when i
was just talking about the novellas that
that's a
oberon is a system through the rings
that they have a um
they have a
they got one of the good planets that's
what the novella
kind of comes down to right they have a
planet where their
their ecosystem is kind of um
it doesn't it's not as is as different
as it can coexist like plants from earth
can co-exist there with their their
local fauna and
there's a character from one of the
earlier stories that pops up there and
yeah you could do you could definitely
do a spin off series there
we have a five dollar super chat from
alex brecht
thank you interesting question there
very interesting i have to think about
that but no thank you for the 4.99
we really appreciate that
justin merritt asks
as a non-reader who do you guess dies in
the finale which big or bigish
characters
i
i'm 99 sure marco's gonna die
i think that's where this is going but
i'm a little bit certain i'm a little
bit less certain about philip but i
think he might sacrifice himself
you know turn on his father to
basically win to basically win the war
for the inners because of um
because of what he because of his
knowledge of the disarmed missile
so marco and philip i don't think
anything is going to happen to drummer
or the rossi crew
and anybody on the rossi
which other major characters
can we even think about
yeah i'll tell you that when i was
watching this and as a as someone who
has read the books
the first time
i felt
i felt pretty i felt pretty uneasy about
clarissa at one point
going into the
azore dragon situation
just because of the way that it was
unfolding and of course she survived
that
i felt like
avicirala
was suspect because of the fact that she
was out there next to series so close to
the action
we don't know how that's going to play
out yet um
but yeah i was worried that they might
kill off anybody because
it was the last season you know and
fred johnson in the in the in the normal
storyline fred johnson dies at this at
this
point and so i was wondering if they
were going to have to
inject a death
to kind of you know
add some add some drama but
we'll see next episode i mean i think
that
i think that there i think that people
should feel
i don't think everyone should feel safe
considering what's going on at the ring
yeah i think people are commenting about
avasarala yeah i forgot about her and
she the fact that they're hinting at her
health
uh yeah it might seem i don't know how
old i i don't really know how old she's
supposed to be in the tv show like she's
much older in the books
you know she's white-haired and you know
she's
physically frail as things go on
they they live a lot longer and they
they have
better um you know medical science and
non you know
drugs that anti-aging drugs that help
you
let you know not only live longer but
your body's in better condition but and
we've got we've got the strange dogs now
even if people die
we don't know what's going to happen
that's the thing that's the thing about
this finale right
just wheel them just wheel them on out
into the glade and
the dogs will the dogs will hook you up
exactly they don't even ask for anything
in return
well i mean i didn't see anything did
you see anything
it seemed like they haven't seen
anything yet
what could go wrong
what could go wrong they're just
adorable little dog-looking
proto-molecule
uh creatures
by the way christina asked earlier if uh
you'd marry her voice
with
if you wanna you know she wants to marry
your voice
that's
that's interesting what
she wants to marry your voice yes
that's what she said yeah
that's funny you know because obviously
anybody who's
anybody out there has at one time or
another recorded their voice and had to
hear it
and you know how how that is and one of
the things about being a youtuber that
is insane is that you have to do that as
a part of your job every day
talk into a microphone then listen to it
and edit it and you know that it's just
it just sounds wrong because you usually
hear it through your inner ear right
yeah i i think i'm getting used to it
now though it's been a year since i
started making videos
yeah you get used to i bet i think that
you know you never really get over it
though you always think that you sound
worse than everybody else definitely
for example my voice when i listened to
it i couldn't believe it because
it's rather sleepy
because i never thought of it that way
it's my natural voice though so yeah it
doesn't feel that way to me when i'm
speaking normally but
when i started making you know
videos
i definitely came to that realization
yeah i had someone tell me i i saw a
comment that made me so annoyed you know
how sometimes when you're scrolling
through your things and you see one that
just
really
makes you
irrationally annoyed i i got i had one
yesterday right before i sat down to eat
and eat my dinner and
someone said
someone said in the comment
you you talked you you decided to talk
specific you know you slowed down your
your speech pattern so you could make
the video longer
and get more view time i i figured you
out
and and stopped watching when i realized
that this was your plan and i'm thinking
you know you're giving me too much
credit there i'm just trying to get
through it you know what i mean i'm not
scamming on how i can get a couple more
seconds of view time by
slowing down my my my cadence my natural
pronunciation or whatever but what does
this one say thank you again christina
for your 9.99
abuse victims don't typically confront
their abusers
it's romantic it's a romanticized tv
viewpoint but ultimately philip is
damaged and unable to fully access his
actions
yeah and that's really you know that's
really the
you know i i think
it gets lost sometimes how how
messed up things are for phillip he i
mean he's literally a
a child soldier
he grew up
that's the only way he can get
validation is through his
is doing what his father wants and his
father is obviously
has bad intentions and and doesn't
protect him or even
you know
give him the opportunity to
have a semblance of a healthy existence
yeah i i think that's one of the things
we've talked about the most uh in these
live streams
and
it's one of the
burning questions about the finale
yeah we're going to get there aren't we
next week
yeah we're we're actually going to find
out
this week actually sorry
yeah in just a few days in just a few
days the expanse will be over
i'm lucky to be able to watch the finale
tomorrow so you've already watched it so
you're quite lucky
you don't have to wait
yeah i'm gonna make the i'm going to
make the um
the preview
today and then i'll be i'll be
going in to start working on my finale
stuff
yeah
i think but yeah i haven't rewatched it
since i watched it the first time and i
i i'm really looking forward to it
it's you know i
i i had to
let's see are you going to do a live
stream after finale yeah we do need to
figure that out we're going to do
we've been doing it on monday because of
other shows
but for the finale it feels like we
should move it much closer to the actual
finale
yeah
i'll be letting you know make sure you
do check my my twitter or my my uh
post feed here on youtube i'll i'll try
to get that out because i mean this is a
one-time event and
you know i really really enjoy this this
story and i'm pretty bummed out that
it's coming to an end and um
i want to definitely try to make the
most out of it
so we're we'll be going for what seems
like
we both live
in really
odd time time zones and and they don't
match up with each other either so
it's going to take some thinking but um
you know you can you can hit me up on
on twitter or
i just posted something about this live
stream yesterday on on youtube so
either one of those places
or the comments of this actual video
whenever it goes live you know whenever
once it's published as a
video on demand you know
let us know what times sound best
because
um
i ha i do have to edit my video my
finale video that takes quite a long
time and i can't do that until the
actual episode comes out so i can't do
it like right when the finale becomes
available but
maybe saturday
yeah i think
that's that's a realistic possibility
and most people would have watched the
finale by then and even if they haven't
they could watch it on saturday morning
or noon and then we could go live i
think that's yeah that's the sweet spot
and i mean i would do more i would
actually do more than just one stream at
this point too i mean i have some other
videos i want to work on but
this is a big deal
i want to talk about it some more i was
talking to aeron from bald move
yesterday and he wasn't able to make it
for this time
so maybe we can
set something up to bring him on that
might not even be
or even a preview in a couple of days
before the finale
like i'm definitely open to doing more
because this is just
it's just coming to an end at this point
yeah we might have another guest as well
i think
yeah
yeah um i think that
we have at least one for the finale
stream and maybe some others so
i'll let you know about that
okay i think uh
we mentioned the time zones there and
this is i think a good time to end it
yes uh yes it's what 5 a.m where you're
at right now or
close to it yes yeah yeah so um
yeah i i think that we should probably
wrap this up here
thanks everyone for coming out and
sticking around
we'll um
we'll be back at least one more time but
maybe a couple of times
before this is all over
do you have anything you want to plug or
you want to talk about before we go
sure thing i uh you can guys you can
check out my uh
youtube channel i think the link to it
is down below in the description box
it's benji tv
i'm going to cover the finale as well i
haven't been doing
weekly breakdowns i only did the
premiere
i might post mine
mine a little bit earlier than you so
you can basically warm up guys before a
pete big video
i'm also covering a new western by the
name of 1883 on my channel at the moment
and we will also be making videos about
resident alien and billions those will
be later in january so definitely check
out my channel thank you for inviting me
on again pete these have been great and
uh the chat has been awesome as well
thank you for watching guys and asking
your questions and commenting we're
trying to read all of your comments but
you know it's hard to get to all of them
so
thanks for watching and thank you for
reminding me on
yeah yeah so yeah i'll be i'll be i'll
have my video out
after the finale airs
the embargo doesn't lift until noon the
next day so
i've been trying to follow that but
we'll see and maybe
maybe that one might come out a little
bit earlier and um yeah so check my
check my twitter or my my posts here and
definitely will be
back to stream before the season's over
so thanks again and
i'll talk to you soon